el fuego de la artillería va dejando
columnas de humo a su paso y con el
grandes extensiones de campo quemado
hasta hace unas semanas la batalla
estaba en una vía paralela y hacia las
rutas del visitante y severodonezk se ha
trasladado a este lugar cada vez más
cerca hacia las ciudades de florian y de
bach mud y ahora se añade un dramatismo
más ya los campos están amarillos la
cosecha está lista para ser recogida y
cuando cae la artillería se prende el
fuego en estos cultivos ropa muestra el
esqueleto de algunos de los cohetes con
los que son atacados pero que aquí lleva
inscrito un 9 332 dice asegura que este
tipo de bombas racimos que son
prohibidas en la guerra son las que
están usando para operaciones ofensivas
estos hombres de la brigada 14 llevan
casi dos meses sosteniendo la posición
de las cercanías de la población de
shivers estratégica para la defensa de
las ciudades de baco multi s obiang
ellos pararon en que pero no aquí están
intentando penetrar por este terreno
todo el tiempo como serpientes y
nosotros no tenemos otra opción que
detenerlo o matar
el ministro de defensa ruso aseguró que
el 16 de julio se acababa ese parón
operativo de las fuerzas rusas la
realidad es que los frentes de batalla
del donbass este parón no se ha sentido
y aquí dicen que siguen viviendo el
mismo infierno que vivieron en la lucha
de severodonezk y lysychansk
en esta vida decenas de hombres y
armamento se mueven tanto apoyo a la
defensa las poblaciones de alrededor son
atacadas permanentemente y en la
retaguardia decenas de equipos médicos
están listos el doctor hugo asegura que
las posiciones de esta zona están bajo
constante fuego
no he visto nada de la pausa operativa
tenemos mucha gente herida que llega
desde las posiciones del frente no
tantas como antes pero casi todos los
días tenemos aquí
[Música]
la permanencia algunos civiles en la
zona hace aún más difícil la labor de
los equipos médicos el doctor vladimir
pasa horas en esta posición a la espera
de pacientes momentos antes del
encuentro atendió a tres niños heridos
en una vivienda pocos metros de donde se
encontraban sus imágenes registradas en
los teléfonos son imposibles de mostrar
por su crudeza
y los niños son los más horribles de
este trabajo me acostumbré a los adultos
a los soldados heridos haber mucha
sangre pero con los niños es muy difícil
en esta vida los anuncios de un
recrudecimiento de la ofensiva rusa
parecen palabras vacías aquí la guerra
nunca se detuvo